former secretary of state hillary
clinton says the supreme court's
monumental abortion ruling could lead to
other decisions turning back the clock
on civil rights in her first on-camera
interview about the ruling we asked her
about justice clarence thomas's written
opinion he said that the court should
reconsider past rulings on contraception
and same-sex marriage
justice thomas has sort of floated that
out there about contraceptive rights and
contraception and about same-sex
marriages but other justices have pushed
back to say no he's really sort of on
his own with that well he believes that
well he may be on his own but he's
signaling as he often did you know
people i went to law school with him
he's been
a person of grievance for as long as
i've known him resentment grievance
anger
and he has signaled
in the past
two lower courts two state legislatures
find cases pass laws
get them up i may not win the first the
second or the third time but we're going
to keep at it so you're saying people
pay attention to yes the people he is
speaking to which are the you know
right-wing very conservative judges and
justices and state legislatures
and the thing that uh is well there's so
many things about it that are deeply
distressing
but women are going to die gail women
will die